-Our next guest is
an award-winning cartoonist,
author, and illustrator.
The latest volume of his
best-selling
graphic-novel series,
"Hilo Book 9: Gina
and the Last City on Earth,"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Judd Winick,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-It's good to be here.
-I can't remember which of these
you were here for
the first time, but this is
now the ninth of these.
-Yes.
-Very popular with the kids.
And you've actually been
going out and visiting schools
to promote the book.
Are those fun visits?
-They are.
It's been -- It's been a month
on the road. About 50 schools.
I do school assemblies.
I kill it.
I'm really good at assemblies.
-You're really --
The kids like it?
I will say --
'Cause at a certain age,
it's very nerve-racking
being in front of young kids
in an assembly. They're not
used to having a good time.
-No, I'm -- [ Scoffs ]
It's, you know --
I play the big rooms.
I'm good at it.
Your cafeterias, your
auditoriums, your cafetoriums.
I'm very --
I mean, mind you --
Mind you,
it's a school assembly.
They're out of class
for about an hour.
-That helps. Yeah.
-Yeah, their level of happiness
is about an 8 out of 10 anyway.
-Right.
-But, you know, I'm not --
I'm not there talking
about fire safety
or from the Dairy Council
about how milk is made.
-Yeah. I know you. You care
not at all about fire safety.
-No. No.
-Now, what about --
Do you ever get --
That's a fun age
for questions
from the audience.
Does anybody ask you
anything memorable?
-No. I mean -- Well, it's gone
wrong a couple of times.
I mean, I --
So, I'm a cartoonist.
I draw. So part
of my presentation
is, I'll draw pictures,
I'll take requests.
Kids ask, "Will you draw Hilo?"
"Yeah, I'll draw Hilo."
"Will you draw
Gina fighting a dinosaur?"
"Sure."
And a couple of years back,
a little girl, second grader,
raised her hand and said,
"Will you draw a penis?"
[ Laughter ]
And they -- All 300 kids
didn't so much laugh,
as they just started
screaming simultaneously.
I mean, like the Beatles
came over from Liverpool
kind of screaming.
-Yeah, that would be
hard to process.
If somebody had the nerve
to do that in second grade,
I think I --
It would blow my mind.
-Oh. I couldn't get 'em back.
It was -- It just --
It was over with.
I mean, they're having
this instantaneous --
-They just start going,
"Draw it! Draw it!"
-Yeah. No.
-You have a, you know,
crazy story
about how you met your wife.
I mean, we all have
good meeting stories,
but you met your wife
on a season of "The Real World."
-Yeah.
-1994. San Francisco.
Here you are...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...with your wife, Pam.
And, I mean, at the time,
you know,
she was a doctor.
-Yeah.
I mean, you know,
I'm a cartoonist.
She's a doctor.
Makes for an interesting combo.
-Basically if you don't meet
on a reality show,
you never meet.
-No. I mean, you know, Pam --
Pam is magna cum laude.
Phi Beta Kappa from Harvard.
Okay. And a doctor.
Me, I, you know -- I make things
up and draw them, right?
So, you know...
-It's very nice, though,
because I feel like
there are so many reality shows
that are designed to make people
who are strangers fall in love.
That's not actually
what "The Real World" was.
And then that's what you guys
managed to pull off.
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, it's helpful
that we started dating
after the show.
-Yeah, that's good.
-Very helpful we started
dating after the show.
-Yeah. Not on camera.
-No.
And they were really pissed
about it, too.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, right, of course.
-Oh, no. We heard later
from the producers.
Like, "We had an episode,
like, a 747
gassed up, ready to go.
But not you guys! You just had
to wait till the cameras left!"
Yeah, that was us.
-So, Hilo --
this wonderful character.
Every time he sees someone,
he screams.
We can sort of see up there.
-Yes.
-He yells, you know, "Aaaah!"
-It's a running gag.
It's been a running --
for about nine --
for about nine years.
-Nine books of this.
-Yes.
-And your fans noticed something
about you and Pam
that you guys had not noticed.
-Yeah, we got
two demographics now.
So we've got, like, the parents
who saw us on the show
and we got the kids.
The parents showed the kids,
like, our Instagram feed,
and the kids will say,
"You and Pam!
You do the Hilo greeting."
It's like, no, we don't.
-There you go. That's...
-And then we --
-So, this is not --
And this, by the way,
is something you've been doing
from early on.
There's the wedding photo.
-That's our wedding picture.
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- I don't know
how it started.
I think -- We met on reality TV.
And rule one is, like,
you never look at the camera.
So now that we look at
the camera, it was like, "Yeah!"
-You're out of practice.
-Yeah, no, it's stupid.
But, you know --
But we're happy.
-You -- I've been lucky enough
to meet your kids.
Your kids are teenagers.
Last time you were here,
you said they loved the books.
Have they outgrown them?
How are they doing with it?
-They are teenagers now.
They are 17 and 14.
And in the early days,
I mean, they were little
when I started the book,
and it was always, you know,
like, "Dad, it's so funny
what Hilo burps.
I like that part."
Now they're older,
and they have notes.
-Yeah.
-You know, it's like, you know,
"I don't think this third act
is working out quite the way
you wanted it to, you know?"
-Does it make you
a little proud
that they have an opinion?
-It's entirely my fault
because they live in my house
and I ruin everything.
-Yeah.
-Like, just watching
a television show or a movie,
it's like, "Okay, okay,
this is the second-act con--
There's a second-act conflict
coming up right now, guys."
-Oh, so they learned it
from you.
-It's my fault.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Well, it's very nice that
you've been able to look inward
and make that observation
about yourself.
-Yeah, I know who I am.
-Congratulations on nine books
in the series.
It is so lovely
to have you back.
You guys, one more time
for Judd Winick.
"Hilo Book 9: Gina
and the Last City on Earth"
is available now.
And everyone in the audience --
Everyone in the audience
is getting a copy.
They're wonderful books.
We'll be right back
with music from Ruston Kelly.